well
because you can't just leave well enough
alone they're making a
because we've all been sitting here
everyone i know you've been sitting here
going
man i sure wish they had an origin story
for cruella de vil
boy are you in luck they do
so um let's check it out let's check out
the trailer for the new uh
cruella de vil movie called cruella
from the very beginning i realized i saw
the world differently than everyone else
that didn't sit well with some people
but i wasn't for everyone
[Music]
i guess they were always scared that i'd
be
a psycho
but a new day brings new opportunities
and i was ready to make a statement
[Music]
how does the same go
[Music]
i am woman hear me raw
i'm just getting started darling
[Music]
the thing is i was born brilliant
[Music]
born fast and a little bit mad
[Applause]
so the joker
so we're just making the joker but we're
calling her cruella de vil
i guess maybe even harley quinn whatever
way i look at it but [ __ ]
the joker
what the [ __ ]
why did we need this
it looks so bad look the whole point and
if i remember correctly because honestly
i'll
you know i'll tell you it's been a
really long time since i've watched 101
dalmatians
but if i remember correctly and you guys
could help me there was a live-action
one too which i don't watch because
why do we not have action when we have
the animated one i don't care if
glenn close played cruella deville it
doesn't [ __ ] matter to me
nikki's right we live in a humane
society
the whole point of cruella de vil was
she was just the super rich
super rich woman who could get whatever
she wanted because she was well to do
right now my take on quella develo was
she probably came from generational
wealth that's what i was assuming
you know her family's always been rich
think of the rothschilds and stuff like
that
um instead now
what we have is a failure to communicate
no
what we have here is um
a woman coming up from the bottom
now she's here as drake would say uh
coming up from the bottom
to become a powerful woman now
here's my question and you guys help me
out here obviously the main person in
this movie is cruella it's named after
cruella
um i sub disney of course disney
am i supposed to
think or or root
because the better word am i supposed to
root for the person that
literally wants to murder puppies
because we know she wants to murder
puppies
so we have to we have to what we have to
sit here and go oh cool i love cruella
de vil because it's emma stone now
and she wants to uh murder puppies
yeah sure why not
so if we're going to do a cruella movie
i have an idea i mean
disney disney now owns owns the rights
to the simpsons because they bought 20th
century fox
why don't we just have a movie called
burns
huh it's called burns because yeah
that's cool like the name like joker
cruella
burns so we'll have a movie called burns
and it'll be how mr burns
came up from the bottom it'll be about
somebody should recut the episode mr
burns teddy bear
just record all his young stuff and make
a really like joker-esque
trailer with it i can't do it because
i'm not good at editing stuff
but if somebody else wants to do it they
could be pretty cool some cool like news
like some [ __ ]
some joker music or with now as we know
that noah did cruella music
um why not
i don't understand the need for this
[ __ ] movie i i don't get it like
she's the bad guy
she wants to murder dogs to make a coat
out of them
how am i supposed to root for this
person
you want children because a disney movie
too root for the person
that wants to murder a bunch of [ __ ]
dogs
there's so much going on in this so i
guess this is her coming up
in the very beginning i realized i saw
the world differently than ever
this is her coming up i guess
everyone else
that didn't sit somebody said it's not
made for you
who's it made for
who's it made for
look 101 dalmatians i watched it as a
kid so i guess it was made for me as a
kid
but it wasn't it's not if they were
making now it's not made for me i
understand that but at least at least
i could say well you know it's made for
kids right
how is this movie made for children this
movie isn't for children
i can't imagine you're going to follow
the [ __ ] psychopath that murders a
bunch of dogs
it's not made for dudes because who what
[ __ ] dude gives a [ __ ] about cruella
deville
it's not made for women because what
[ __ ] psychopathic women are gonna
[ __ ]
be in love with the person who wants to
murder puppies
[ __ ] dude even joker even joaquin
phoenix joker
had some sort of moral compass tainted
as it was
did a lot of horrible things i
understand he's a villain
but he had something you know society
had failed him and
you know and he couldn't get his meds
you know and he took it out on people
that he thought were evil
she's just killing puppies the puppies
aren't gonna
the puppies that did a bit of [ __ ]
oh god are they gonna do did a [ __ ]
dalmatian bite her
is there gonna be like a i haven't
[ __ ] seen this movie but when it
comes out
watch this happen and you can you guys
are gonna you're gonna clip this
and you're gonna say look he was right
they're gonna have a scene where
dalmatian bites her i saw that they
growled at her but
a dalmatian bites her or she's gonna say
something in the lines when she sees dom
after the dominations growl at her she's
gonna go they would make a great coat
or i'll be wearing you one day or
something [ __ ]
like that who's this who the [ __ ] is
this made for
these aren't disney films
this is the piles of [ __ ] hot garbage
[ __ ] disney gets rid of gina carano
for tweeting something but they'll make
an entire movie glorifying
the person who murders puppies for
children
this this doesn't not feel hardly
quinnish at best
joker at worst but i wasn't for everyone
[Music]
i guess they were always scared and
you're right you know what bambi they
killed the mom
but bam you are they gonna make a
prequel for bambi
where they follow the hunter because
that's what this movie is are you gonna
follow the hunter that killed bambi's
mom
is that what we're gonna do are we gonna
make a movie called
hunter and we'll have jason momoa play
the hunter
and it was [ __ ] he was abused as a
kid that's why he killed bambi
it's a [ __ ] horse [ __ ] man
that i'd be a psycho
[Laughter]
and cruella deville
was not a psycho
she was just a
she was a rich [ __ ] that thought she
could have everything in the world she
wasn't a psycho
she wasn't broken and she wasn't society
[ __ ] boasting
which by the way remind me to play the
snyder cut trailer
in case you want to see the movie now
but i'm going to do that next because
that reminded me
but what the actual [ __ ]
who is this
made for see and the downside is to
things like disney plus
and stuff coming out directly for disney
plus or coming out directly for hbo max
is you'll never know if the movie did
good because they don't have to release
their numbers and they don't
so you don't even have like you know the
[ __ ] libertarian
[ __ ] thing like free market or decide
man the free market's not gonna [ __ ]
decide
man because this isn't coming out in
theaters this is coming out directly for
disney plus
and a lot of this once you take the
theater that's one of the big downsides
as much as i prefer watching movies at
home
that's one of the big downsides to the
theaters going out is that
there's no way to know if a movie
actually did well or not because if a
movie [ __ ] bombs
they're not going to tell you it bombed
or if nobody liked they're not going to
care
you know no one's going to [ __ ] care
if you have hbo max for if you have a
bex if you have hbo max
you you can use your cable company to
log in
you use your cable company to log into
[ __ ] uh eight to
hbo max just by using like logging in
with your
uh cable provider be
a psycho
i'm sorry now i'm sorry now
i am sorry we've reached a level where
disney
is being inspired by a psychopathic
clown which that movie was great i love
the joker but
uh talk about the clown movie they go we
could do that but we'll use one of our
disney characters to do it
what's [ __ ] next what's [ __ ] next
new day brings new opportunities
[Music]
her hair would burn her [ __ ] entire
hair
this hairspray in there would burn so
also
just something else [ __ ] cruella de
vil is now also
magic she's not just crazy old broad
that wants to make a [ __ ]
coat out of puppies she's literally
magic
yeah she's a witch that's what she is
crowtherville is now a [ __ ] witch
look don't get me wrong emma stone could
get it
no one's arguing that okay
but now she's a witch
[Music]
i am woman hear me roar
oh oh and apparently
she robs banks now
she's a bank robber
what is this ocean's 101
this is [ __ ] i shouldn't care this
much about this
but i'm sick of this i get that it's a
movie
i don't have to watch it i can ignore
this i could go on my life
but enough is enough
stop
i'm turning into a psychopath
[Music]
i'm just getting started
shut up
also that's white face also you're
appropriating [ __ ]
i don't know irish culture
oh this is her this is this is her all
this lost moment you could tell
like i'm assuming i don't watch this
movie with [ __ ] paint by numbers
[ __ ]
this is when they when they um
when they probably kicked her out of
high society
and oh let's not forget you know what
else is gonna happen
there's gonna be a man that [ __ ] with
her it's gonna be a
man that just wouldn't let her live
you know it you know i'm right you know
there's gonna be some sort of man
that drove her down this path and that
was her crying and she said no to men
and said yes to killing [ __ ] puppies
[Music]
the thing is oh and there it is that
this is what
that was probably her running away as a
kid and from what wayne manor
yes i was born crazy
yeah you probably as an orphan i was
born brilliant
no you weren't
her entire motivation was clothing
stop trying to make cruella de vil
deeper
than what her entire motivation is
[Music]
this this part right here see this
this here this is this is them her or
this is them wanting to make her
uh harley quinn that that's what you see
this is them wanting to make her harley
quinn
look at that huh it's harley quinn
without the deep backstory
harley quinn was motivated by she was a
therapist and joker [ __ ] with her mind
and beat her up and that's what happened
we get
here's what we get i'll tell you what we
get we get
[ __ ] cruella [ __ ]
deville
cruella deville is just bad because of
reasons
oh yeah you saw more dalmatians i told
you damace is going to be a big part of
this it's
a dalmatian is they released the hounds
when the the [ __ ] orphanage she lived
at
they released the [ __ ] hounds
and that's why she's holding a grudge so
she's got to kill
[ __ ] puppies
look look they're trying to do the f
what what you're gonna say
i live in a society let's see this is
[ __ ] her again
look at they're they're trying to make
her look like heath ledger's joker after
he blew up the [ __ ] hospital
[Music]
are ya is that who you are
because you look like emma stone
i don't think i'll be watching this
movie
i'm gonna watch the movie obviously i
have to watch the movie
because now i need to know if i was
right that's how they get you
they get you because it's bad they get
you because it's bad
and then you watch the movie [ __ ]
anyway
it's joker it is true joker's trending
on twitter
so obviously i didn't have some crazy
original thought
everybody knows this movie's just
basically the [ __ ] disney joker
call from now everyone call this
disney's joker because that's what this
is